here again with famous author Jeffrey
Moore and what are we doing last time we
were talking about this Gerald Conte's
letter we were and and this is part of a
process in the invention we call read
and react where a lot of academics is
you read somebody else's ideas and then
you react to them and you write an essay
based on your reactions so we spent a
bunch of time you're my guinea pig here
and I thought I appreciate you being the
guinea pig so we spent some time
building up some ideas that you were
having in reaction to the letter and I
their summarized here on the page I'd
love for you to just sort read them out
and we at the bottom half we kind of
formalized it and then we're going to
talk today about where do you go from
here this is very nice everyone should
have a Geoffrey Moore to make a synopsis
of their thoughts which i believe is
which I believe is the function of the
Khan Academy all right so this is so
these are some of the notes that you got
from what I had said in the last video
micromanaging standardized testing can
strangle the creativity of the great
teacher yes I did say that in the last
video used to believe it I thought about
a little bit more I definitely I
definitely believe that micromanaging
strangles the creativity of a great
teacher you know if they tell you day by
day what to do you're your individual
unit tests and homeworks are dictated by
someone else I think that definitely
hurts that the standardized testing I've
thought about it a little bit more I
mean most of the standardized tests that
I've seen especially at the state level
the ones that you know to measure
whether students are in grade level or
what or not whatever else they are kind
of a minimum bar you know it's not
always obvious because the results
aren't always great but if you look at
them they are a minimum of art I think
most great teachers will look at those
as minimum bars and so I don't know if
it necessarily you know if great
learning is happening the kids are going
to learn a hundred different things and
they should also be able to meet meet
the five things and get them past that
that that minimal bar so I don't know
whether the standardized testing by
itself a strangles strangles the
creativity I think the place where where
that could be the case is a situation
where you have a great teacher in a
tough environment where
the kids are well behind grade level and
just then that minimum bar is no longer
a minimum bar anymore it could be a very
difficult bar and so what does that
teacher do in fact you're going to get
to that I think in 10 gaming okay yeah
so let's let's look at the other ones
whenever the public be that a governor
or politician or superintendent gets
worried about the education system the
reaction is to place more constraints on
it and make it more rigid this is I
still believe this this is the way that
is a very cool I'd never thought about
that that is a really cool idea this
might de-risk some of the worst
classroom some of the ones that are
really failing where students are not
getting even to a minimal level but it
has a horrible consequence of
suppressing the very best teachers i
still believe this i mean this all goes
back to okay you're worried you're
micromanaging micromanaging is bad it's
kind of a march to mediocrity I agree
with that if you if you tell the best
teachers what to do hour by hour they're
not going to be the best teacher the
solution that they are placing on
teachers like Gerald Conte is not the
correct one I believe that there are
solutions that can bring up the
standards of the worst performing
schools without necessarily holding back
the Gerald Conte's of the world I still
think that all I think it's you know
it's not an easy challenge I think it
would be more of their experiments that
need to be tried to see if we can if we
can do this and then let's see you wrote
top-down state-mandated curricula that
have been have to be filed to a tee
while they might help d risk some of the
worst performing classrooms have the
negative impact of holding back the very
best and this is I did say that I think
this was this was the thesis sentence we
constructed what we were trying to say
if you had to just put it all under one
sentence so I guess my question would be
here you've had a week to think about
this how do you feel about this as this
is everything I'm going to say is
somewhere represented in this sentence I
agree I I definitely agree with the top
down state mandate curricula because
this is much more about micromanaging
then I mean you you could have
standardized testing without a top-down
state mandated curriculum you could tell
a teacher look you do whatever you see
is fit you use whatever text books you
want you do whatever activities you want
but at the end of the year we're going
to just do a test to just make sure your
kids are at some minimal bar I don't
think that is is what I'm nestled
against it's the
this week by week do this hour by hour
and you have to use this textbook you
have to use this test you have to use
these problem sets so this is what I
text you wrote synopsis of what I I say
yeah I'll write a little bit about the
motivations of administrators and
officials why they're even thinking
along these lines that's all about the
test scores and the number of kids that
have to take remedial math but then I
would really focus in on how state
mandates have to be followed to the
letter while they might help a classroom
that is really broken are definitely
going to hold back more successful
performing classrooms and then I would
write about alternate solutions that
might be able to address the broken
classrooms without breaking the non
broken ones yeah I think this is I still
feel this way okay cool so now so now
we've got some invention that we think
is pretty interesting and we're going to
apply some organizational exercises to
it now sound I've had a conversation
offline this isn't exactly the way he
writes but I again he's agreeing to play
guinea pig with me to sort of walk
through this system because I think in
my experience in teaching freshman
English this is a way in which a lot of
people have been able to come to terms
with writing maybe they're not quite as
gifted at it as some others this is kind
of fun so what we're going to do is
let's let's double click on any one of
these ideas in red either in the thesis
sentence or in this paragraph below it
and we'll just start developing that one
okay well I guess I mean why so we'll
start with a thesis sentence okay all
right so that's the first claim we have
two claims here if you'll notice one is
these curriculum might help d risk some
of the worst performing classrooms so
let's take that one so that is now a sub
claim it's not a thesis sentence but
it's going to become a topic sentence
meaning it's part of the thesis that
we're going to develop in a paragraph so
the topic sentence might say it's
something like it is you know
state-mandated curricula might help d
risk some of the worst performing
classrooms so that's a claim right do
you have any evidence for that claim why
do you believe that well I don't have
evidence I guess you know that would
hold up in a court of law type of
evidence but I you know if I were to
kind of imagined in my head a classroom
where maybe the lectures that are being
given aren't completely accurate or
they're not able to cover all of the
material in the class or me and maybe
has
absolutely nothing to do with the
teacher maybe it's a the students are
acting up and it's disrupting some of
the other students in the classroom
there there I could see look if you have
some if you have some well actually I
would take that back i mean we're
talking bout state state state mandated
curricula yeah i mean the issues that
you're essentially trying to solve for
is if there's a if there's a teacher
that has bad judgment and is you know
even though this is math class they have
the the students finger painting the
whole time because they just think that
little help there you know eventually
help their mathematics then telling that
teacher no look you've got to use this
textbook on on october fifth the
students have to take this test it's
going to have these questions in it then
I'll it's October 18th you're going to
have to make them do this that could
help d risk that obviously talking about
an extreme circumstance though what you
did was interesting so the claim the
claim and we were looking at an extreme
circumstance because this is not the
core of our thesis we're actually just
trying to say the opposite of our thesis
has some validity and we're trying to
just export briefly well you didn't have
so we didn't have any data for that now
by the way one of the wonderful things
about the web these days is we probably
could go on the web find data and I
think by the way in college you're
increasingly expected to do that but for
the moment during this talk we're not
going to do that I'd rather be here so
if i wanted to collect it i'll probably
do a search for something like testing
or not testing state curricula improving
test scores or improving outcomes and i
probably could find some state results
that are doing i think i think we both
were both very confident does that kind
of stuff would happen so when you're
writing an essay i make a claim I might
so to pass one path is I'll go to the
web I'll enter something a search
argument and I will get some evidence
for that claim increasingly that is the
standard expected in a college essay but
if you're writing the essay say on an
exam you're in the middle of an exam you
can't do that right so and sometimes
it's not it's not as a big enough point
to do it so then you give examples and
it was interesting to watch you
construct your example because you ended
up saying well if there's if there's
problems in accuracy in the teachers
presentation of the material if there's
problems with coverage they're not
getting it covered
and then you went into the students
acting up you thought no that way that's
not that's not part of the deal so you
took that one off and these if they have
the bad judgment to not do things those
are all examples of when the claim would
be true and so and so all you're doing
is you're giving your we call it backing
up the claim now let's back up a claim
that you care more about so so I'm not
sure whether that's the alternate
solutions or the holdback more
successful classrooms I actually don't
believe you owe you yet Michael
micromanaging will hold let's just do
that micromanaging would hold back more
successfully performing classrooms so
that's another topic sense for another
paragraph so do you believe that and if
then why do you believe that I
absolutely believe that I mean that's
you know that's the teacher who's gone
out and written their own exam that
tests much deeper conceptual
understanding than the one that comes
from the publishing company the teacher
that has their students constructing
proofs of things or exploring math at a
much deeper level than that is expected
by the state tests that teacher to tell
them no no no you have to use the
publishers test you have to do you know
you have to make these kids do 200
problems of busy work as opposed to
having these students try to do
something creative or inventive that's
unfortunate that's that's holding back
everyone's experience ok so again what
if you is if you were listening to this
and we're going to kind of kind of wrap
this up with an idea here in just a
second Sal gave three different examples
of how a micro managed approach to
testing would hold back a creative
teacher and so again in the paragraph e
he was supporting this he would be
saying he stayed his claim and then he'd
give those examples right one after
another in sentence is just the way did
in conversation and that would make
start to make up and organize the body
of a paragraph now I want to close this
with a with a model I want you to do a
little drawing for me if you wear and
this model is called the toolman model
and you can look it up on the web tou
lmin Toman was a lawyer teaching other
lawyers how to how to make arguments and
he's got a rather it's a compass a
complex model we're going to look at it
in another
another video in detail but I just want
to give you the simplified version of it
and it's basically just a line where you
put claim on the right and you put
evidence on the left and the idea is
whenever you make a claim you've got to
link it to some evidence sometimes the
evidence is data sometimes the evidence
as examples so in a more scientific
paper you'd actually refer to test data
but in a more humanities aren't in paper
you'd probably refer to examples
although you might refer back to a line
in a poem like Ozymandias okay data and
examples and then the third part of the
model is a little bar that goes down in
the middle he called the warrant which
is kind of a abstract term but it's
anything you would say to connect the if
the evidence did connection between the
evidence in the claim isn't obvious you
have to put an extra sentence in there
say and here's why the evidence warrants
me making this claim and you read or
believing in this claim and so that's so
it would use that model in the next in
the next video we'll talk a little bit
more about how you can use this model in
a more complete version of this model to
help structure paragraphs it should kind
of get a big picture what's been going
on here because that's as your guinea
pig I want to understand what's
happening yeah I read the last I read
you know this this thing down here in
the last video you had me react to it
essentially and then you recorded as
what I was reacting to it and through
that you're able to mine out my claims
and then the whole point of this one is
we picked a couple of claims and you had
essentially me go through the exercise
of coming up with the evidence and maybe
the warrants to for a few of them we
didn't do all of them and but maybe now
we're ready to start exactly and this is
part of the transition in our Chevron
model that we had one that said assess
the writing situation then do invention
than do organizing this is the
transition from invention to organizing
I so we're beginning to organize our
thoughts